[Musik]
ich weiß nicht wie es euch geht ich bin
jetzt seit einer woche zu hause und hat
mir die auszeit ja ganz gut wenn du
nicht diese gesellschaft wäre
du weißt du was der mais und die cdu
gemeinsam haben
das kommt beide sind konservativ bewegen
konserven normal
[Musik]
ja
theologe politiker wenden können
seit den arbeiten an
[Musik]
wir sagen dass jetzt auf drei was wir
für 12 30 uhr eine frau therapie was
hallo schönen tag zusammen
in china gehen wir jetzt gerade die
scheidungsraten durch die decke also ich
sehe an ihrem lächeln sie freuen sich
auf jeden fall dass ihre berufliche
zukunft gesichert ist ich mache mir
sowieso über meine zukunft keinen stress
weil erstmals sexualität und
partnerschaft ist immer was was ein
leben lang eine art und weise thema ist
sehr deutsche beziehung sagen auch
findet einfach nicht statt alles also
eigene erziehung sozialisierung hat ja
auch immer was mit der eigenen
sprachfähigkeit zum thema sexualität und
partnerschaft zu tun wie war es denn bei
ihm wie wurden sie aufgeklärt sind sie
aufgeklärt worden smith unangenehmen
dieses gespräch nicht wie ist das
eigentlich wenn man sich in zeiten der
quarantäne trend wie wird der hamster
kauf aufgeteilt gibt es offizielle
regeln
also ich bin keine offiziellen regeln
das würden wir dann aber im detail
machen wenn sie dieselbe würden wir sie
noch mal am zweiten und dann jede
einzelne dose ins bild halten und sie
würden dann sagen costa oder poker
vielleicht schaffen sie es ja doch noch
eben auch das ruder umzureißen
viel spaß noch in der quarantäne
das fand ich jetzt eigentlich eher so
mittel hilfreich weil man nicht
vielleicht jemanden anrufen der sich
wirklich mit quarantäne aus geld denkst
du auch an denen man dann den ich denke
[Musik]
herr lauterbach ich bin mit fabian
eingesperrt wieder um gottes willen um
gottes willen wirklich haben sie einen
tipp für was wir noch machen können
also mich an doch der abstand zu klein
zu sein
also ich würde ja genau 90 noch ein
bisschen ein bisschen so wie genau sie
haben sich im home office ein bisschen
gehen lassen herr lauterbach wo ist ihre
pflege naja ich muss jünger aussehen
meine töchter mahnen an die zeit des
legte seit vorbei
es kam nicht so begriffe wie peinlich
und so weiter von daher bin ich etwas
vorsichtig mit der pflege im moment wenn
sie obenrum schon keine fliege anhaben
wie sieht es dann unten rum aus und kein
kommentar wie vertragen die sich denn
die zeit herr lauterbach
ich mache das was ich am schlechtesten
kann ich koche hausarbeit ist grau
kochen des grauens vor was würden sie
sagen ist schlimmer hausarbeit oder
politik also im subjektiv ist die
hausarbeit schlimmer objektiv die
politik weil sie in der spd sind ehrlich
gesagt jetzt bin ich dann eine
untergeordnete rolle
aber das schlimmste ist wenn man
sozusagen politik machen muss und zu
hause dann kombiniert sich somit die
hausarbeit mit der politik das könnte
man niemandem was haben es dann sie
haferflocken
also hab ich dann dass wir gar nicht
aber sagen wir aber half erholung sowie
politiker sind ja vor wieder wir haben
es dann überhaupt mit klopapier haben
sie noch also toilettenpapier ist noch
da klopapier ist noch da und dann sind
da natürlich all die berichte die
zeitungen die niesen pamphlete die mich
auch während meiner kandidatur für den
spd parteivorsitz begleitet haben die
liegt denn hier noch etwas vergisst aber
ich wüsste wofür sie zum einsatz kämen
wenn das klopapier also knapp viele
politiker gehören ja einfach altersmäßig
dann doch zur risikogruppe werden dazu
harte maßnahmen ergriffen auch weil sie
angst haben dass am ende sonst nur noch
philipp am tory burch bleibt also wenn
nur er übrig bliebe das wäre tatsächlich
eine katastrophe für jedermann und das
alleine würde die massive also
einschränkung des öffentlichen lebens
wie wir jetzt vor uns haben
rechtfertigen aber ist nicht der moment
richtige witze zwar sieht es
wissenschaftlich aus bringt das was zum
lachen war einer ernst zu nehmenden
lungenkrankheit wenn man da was zu
lachen hat gab es tatsächlich der immun
aber nur helfen also einfach weiterhin
das instagram profil von andy schoy
angucken kann man darüber auch beim
lachen nicht überdosieren das ist ganz
klar dass das profil wurde da richtig
schlimmer risiko sein wenn ich das
richtig sehe was denken sie wie lange
wird die heute schon noch senden können
wenn die zahl der infizierten zu schnell
runter ging
wie die qualität der heute show stand
dann könnten wir dann hätten wir die
krise im gerät er sicherlich nicht mehr
lange auf sendung ist vielen dank also
ich hab gesehen quarantäne ist
eigentlich gar nicht so schlimm
ich persönlich freue mich sogar auf ein
bisschen traute zweisamkeit alter der
club hatte er wieder alles wahnsinn
inhaltlich stark satire comedy gruppe
ich habe es noch drauf also ich würde
den kanal direkt abonnieren und auf
gefällt mir drücken wenn ich das nicht
schon getan hätte das war wirklich stark
[Musik]